foreign
[Music]
hey Duffer Brothers I usually prefer my
seizure-inducing episodes to give me at
least a few minutes to warm up this is
almost as bad as the Porygon episode of
Pokemon that's in lots of Japanese
children to the hospital now how many
sins was I gonna give this one again
sunflower no that's not right rainbow no
not that either four to the left close
enough for it is
she kept showing the girl in the room
she kept showing you a lot of things
though so why zero in on the girl and
not for instance the safe other than to
move the plot along
chucking a file folder to the floor
rather than handing it to the person
wanting to look at it who's standing
directly behind you does anyone look
familiar this entire file is
you know how many children are reported
missing in the U.S every year 460
000. are you telling me this woman in
rural Indiana somehow sorted through all
of them without the internet to find a
handful of kids taken by a shady
government lab also are we supposed to
believe the top secret government
organization that gave this woman a
lobotomy just to keep their stuff hidden
wouldn't immediately search this home
and confiscate all of these files two
quote another allegedly sociopathic
pre-teen I don't think so
nosebleeds how does she does she have
any blood left in her head hold on in
the first season Ellie needed a sensory
deprivation tank to do psychic stuff in
this season she shown to need blindfold
and static but here she can do it while
sleeping is the TV even on can I get
some consistency for these powers please
her nose isn't even bleeding she gave me
this number and he came here looking for
her wow Not only was Ellie able to
locate one of the 4.5 billion people on
the globe with her psychic powers but
they allowed her dream to end just as
her and was making a suspicious phone
call for Elda over here may wonders
never cease Jane Jane Jane who are you
fooling with me me me
title screen after over five minutes
just seems too Bourgeois to me how did
she know which bus to get on how does
she know how buses work I don't even
know how buses work watch it kid
Chicagoans but also show has time for
this remember how Hopper and the Gang
were about to find their facility
stormed by a pack of demogorgons please
don't let this be the Mandalorian season
3 parole scientist episode of stranger
things
[Music]
running a criminal outfit and not
locking the door Stringer Bell would
never dream Circle I think she's a
schizo or something thinking dream
circles are so ridiculous that they must
be a sign of mental illness when you
yourself were just attacked by imaginary
spiders
[Music]
let me guess your policeman he also
stops you from using your gifts well
technically Hoppers never forbid Nell
from using her powers she just has to
stay in the cabin while using them and
you might say wait you're not really
gonna drop us in for such a small
technicality right and I'd say welcome
to TV since we get a little sin happy
when television series have the
potential to be so much better than
detouring into filler think of it as a
kind of
magic thing The Duffer brother said to
explain L's powers to the Netflix
Acquisitions team somehow makes it into
the script I guess
I just feel
[Music]
you're telling me Shirley's a human
radar detector or some oh so
psionic Illusions and telekinesis are
fine but you draw the line of telepathic
GPS you know when I say it out loud it
does sound ridiculous but doubting
powers in the age of satanic Panic is
certainly a sin not that I want to
explain how I know this but that knife's
gonna be pretty dull if you actually
ever need it but like us
show as time for this Outcast cliche
Hopper could be dead right now
for all you know ah who am I kidding
show doesn't have the stones to make
that one stick the criminals we simply
make them pay for their crimes
nonchalant justification for murder I
kept my anchor inside
I tried to hide from it but then that
pain
festered
and finally are confronted my pain
I began to heal oh I see the messages
Hollywood intends to teach it to us
Revenge heals all wounds got it
can't I guess you could say l needs more
training
oh we got jokes y'all gotta keep this
on track
L holds her hand and screams while using
her powers cliche this headline is just
retired come on no newspaper editor with
ink for blood would ever let that run
above a story and I can back that up
with literally minutes of research in my
own overconfidence also just how many of
these secret lab government spy guys
live in Chicago they all get a special
deal on condos there or something I
don't buy this group staying quiet
enough long enough for this to work
there's a table right behind you where's
the phone if there's no risk if you
played Risk game takes six hours to set
up there's nothing fun about it on the
list of painful things I'd rather do it
rank slower than having my crotch kicked
by a Muay Thai Master after waxing my
teeth with jalapeno honey oh off
with your unearned slow motion walk hey
your bathroom is leaking I know been
focused on our killing spree and all but
if I had her power step one would be
tricking myself into a fancy apartment
or at least something nicer than an
underpass in flaming Barrel okay
contestants you have a minute and a half
saying this out loud right by the door
where the cashier can hear you over the
sound of sloshing water waiting this
long into the Montage to steal money
[Applause]
put that background blow your head off
does she not know when the Illusions
wear off why wasn't someone at least
watching the door we were only stealing
from the war criminal billionaires who
owned this place really do war criminal
billionaires find a lot of profit in
places that sell Bait and Tackle and
booze looks like a mom and pop place to
me steal from them sure but don't
Gaslight them because that is a sin too
far
not kicking his gun away remember kids
gun safety
go
is there a silent alarm in the bathroom
how the did the police get to a
rural gas station robbery so quick
no blindfold or static you know what 10
cents for playing fast and loose with
11's Powers again
they went through a montage of picking
masks only to take them off as soon as
they confront the guy but I won't
because this is how you do Revenge
unburdened by disguise or false pretense
just the blood rushing in your ears as
your soul screams for recompense for for
oh
I think I might need to talk to my
therapist
stealing a move from James Earl Jones
without asking I know he likes to alter
deals but theft is theft the plot
perfect placement of this photo
this is a sin for not robbing a bank and
being cold I was ones just like you you
know that oh you were also stuck in a
filler Arc despite being the main
character harsh but that's why I'm hard
on you because I see in you my past
mistakes equating pressuring a young
girl into cold-blooded murder too tough
love what kind of money you mean
why is Dottie collecting part of the pot
when funshine won was there a side bet
was there a tie do they know how to play
poker do I is this happening now is it
just a vision is it 11's power are we
even supposed to care anymore your
mother said you're here for a reason
remember yeah what was that reason
exactly of that or of this entire
episode I'm telling you my bed is still
on the safe but I can save them good
because Bob's really growing on me and I
relate to the dorky guy finding his
tribe without having to compromise his
dorkiness go save him Mel
yeah that fan got shot like 50 times I'm
calling that it still runs or
that the kids inside are still able to
run because they should be dead dead how
did she escape on foot so easily they
had that many guys and they didn't even
bother to establish a perimeter that's
just shoddy police work so many
nosebleeds watched entire seasons of
Shonen anime with less
giving off major stranger danger Vibes
by not waiting for El's permission to
join her and sitting down anyway
I swear you are the worst sister
look what you did you little jerk enough
breather
can I interest you folks in some of our
Heavenly cheesecake sister sisters Holly
I like twins think of it as a kind of
magic your ancestors called it magic are
you real are you an angel
[Music]
I can hear you popping a hernia over
here
ah my Edibles just kicked in